so when we think about aviation as
regards flying today really all starts
in 1903
now the original Wright took humans on a
powered flights in the United States for
the very very first time didn't go very
high didn't go very far but that's where
today's history of aviation really
starts
so this replica behind us was actually
copied from the original Wright Flyer
that for many years was displayed in
this museum eventually it went back to
the United States after the Second World
War and this replica took its place
[Music]
so with the Wright brothers we travel
just a few hundred yards and not very
high off the ground
how could we make aviation something
that was really useful that could take
us places behind me is a triplane it's
the av Road triplane of 1909 one of the
very first aircraft to fly in the UK and
then just to its side is another
aircraft a biplane by Samuel Cody it was
a failed competition design for the army
but it showed you how we were trying to
improve the process of flight
[Music]
so we are now entering the age of the
firsts the really significant aviation
records over my right shoulder the
actual aircraft that flew across the
Atlantic the first nonstop flights John
Alcock Arthur Brown 1919 they thought
they were going to land on a nice grassy
strip in Ireland turned out to be a bog
so they'd rather sank up to there under
carriages but it was the first
transatlantic flight
[Music]
so we're now at the stage where we want
to fly further and faster just behind me
we have the de Havilland [ __ ] moth that
Amy Johnson flew all the way to
Australia the very first woman to fly
all of those thousands of miles
just over there we have the Supermarine
6b aircraft the world record speed
holder in 1931 the designer RJ Mitchell
went on to design the Spitfire
so we have this new realm of the air the
military perhaps more than anyone else
were very anxious to go faster and
faster we are very close to to the most
famous aircraft from the Second World
War the Spitfire and the hurricane
so the propeller could only take her so
fast how could we travel faster still
Frank Whittle an inventor who had come
up with a new type of propulsion system
he was keen to get even faster the
propulsion system was called the jet
engine
this is the very first jet engine to fly
an aircraft in the United Kingdom
it's named after Frank Whittle its
inventor it's the whittle w1 but still
we wanted to travel faster how could we
achieve supersonic flight
[Music]
so we broke the sound barrier we even
sent passengers at twice the speed of
sound with engines like this one of
Conchords original engines
but that wasn't the future the future
was using engines like this the rb211
this is the type of engine used on
today's wide-body Jets quieter more
efficient but what are the future all of
this has happened in just a few decades
what happens next how fast will we be
traveling and where will we go
[Music]
you
[Music]